si elle fait sa tournée comme tous les
jours dans les allées de géants
batelière myriam oyonnax le coeur gros
après des années de difficultés
financières le groupe vient de se
séparer de géants océanis la vente a été
validé par l'autorité de la concurrence
c'est la fin d'une époque
c'est beaucoup d'émotion par rapport
avec la vente effective du robin on sait
simplement que le magasin est en vente
et bella s'est conclu ses effectifs
aujourd'hui donc c'est une histoire qui
se tourner pour nous
et c'est triste c'est vraiment très très
triste auteur du rachat le groupe
hayotte qui acquiert donc son quatrième
hyper 3100 mètres carrés 26 boutiques
ils l'exploitent rassoul en seniors au
marché le repreneur entend rénover le
magasin entre autres priorités le
souhait de baisser significativement les
prix sur la zone de chalandise
à travers cette acquisition d'élargir
l'offre on a parlé à l'instant de
profiter de cette acquisition pour
valoriser et renforcer la présence de la
production et de l'industrie le calme au
sein des linéaires et enfin de forme et
de proposer des programmes de formation
sur mesure aux collaborateurs avec
lesquels nous nous allons travailler
mais le groupe lyonnais n'a t'il
vraiment jouer à armes égales dans la
guerre des hypers pas sur un ancien
avocat claude michalon s'est penchée
pendant des années sur un fait méconnu
le remboursement des taxes d'octroi de
mer de 1993 à 2010 les opérateurs
économiques ont fait des centaines de
procès pour récupérer l'octroi de mer
qu'ils avaient payé en important les
produits avec à la clé des sommes
conséquentes
c'est colossal c'est colossal à titre
d'exemple on peut citer un groupe de la
de la grande distribution en martinique
qui réclamait toutes procédures
confondues le concernant qui déclamait
63 millions d'euros de remboursement
donc ce couple a dû laisser pas le plus
gros seins donc on imagine ce que ça
peut donner pour les autres l'octroi de
mer a priori répercutée sur les prix et
les consommateurs auraient donc été
finalement remboursé aux opérateurs
juste après la grève de 2009
à cette période
il ya une série de transactions est à
dire qu' il ya des accords amiables pour
mettre fin au contentieux et toutes les
entreprises comme un seul homme se
désiste de leur action devant les
tribunaux
nous on arrête nos procédures mais pas
gratuitement
a priori non a priori non donc il y
aurait une transaction
il semblerait que ces paiements été fait
sur le budget de l'état m'enfin c'est
toujours le contribuable quelques bas
mais parmi les grands groupes
économiques
il y en a approché par les mêmes avocats
parisiens qui a refusé d'attaquer en
justice c'est le groupe lyonnais est ce
que vous estimez que le fait que votre
groupe aux familles refusaient de faire
la demande de remboursement d'octroi de
mer ça a joué dans vos difficultés
financières peut-être façon avec des si
aujourd'hui on pourrait refaire le monde
donc ça a été fait comme ça ça a été un
choix délibéré
vous avez fait ce choix il juste pour
protéger les intérêts de la martinique
combien les concurrents de yoann les
groupe hayotte est parfaite
ont-ils finalement touché seule la
douane le gouvernement et les avocats
disposent de l'information
l'opacité reste totale sur un épisode
économique qui a peut-être rebattu les
cartes de la concurrence